congrats on the movie it's going to be a
huge hit i i know you already know that
thank you so much uh uh uh you never
know but thank you so much
i'm willing to bet a good chunk of money
it's gonna be
um it was a lot of fun making it that's
for sure i can only imagine um if
someone has never seen
anything that you've done what's the
first thing that you want them to watch
what's yeah what's the first thing you
want them to watch
wow
that's a good question but i'll have to
say wonder woman
yeah
yeah i was gonna say i heard that's good
yeah thank you
[Laughter]
so dwayne has a tequila company and ryan
has a gin company
and since no one is watching i'm just
curious um which one tastes better
oh my god it's uh
they're both pretty good solid it
depends on what you're feeling like
having you know
i like that diplomatic answer that was
good always
uh listen i i would imagine what
actually working with dwayne and ryan
what actually maybe surprised you about
working with them that maybe you weren't
expecting
uh i don't know i don't feel like
anything
i don't think like i was surprised by
any of them we've been
i got to work with ryan and i got to
work with dwayne before so we've known
each other and we've you know we
we felt very familiar and comfortable
uh working together
um but i don't think like i discovered
anything new if anything i feel like
i love them even more and i appreciate
them even more because they're both so
smart and talented and hard workers but
also at the same time amazing family
guys and fathers and and and
generous partners to be working with and
um
and it was great
right so they basically slipped you a
five dollar bill to say that i get it oh
no
much more than five much more than whole
they had to wire it right
one of the things i don't think people
realize is what it really takes to do
these action set pieces in movies like
this so
using the example of say the third act
mind chase you know like in the big
vault um maybe could you sort of explain
what it really takes to make a sequence
like that well it's hours and days and
weeks really if not months of of work of
of first of all designing everything we
have an amazing second unit director
george cottle who worked hand in hand
with our wonderful wonderful director
russian thurber and they designed
everything and they had
teams to check if we it's actually
something that we can do and then you
rehearse this and then you rehearse this
with cameras and that it's like
endless amount of days to just work on
one action sequence there's so much
thought and effort and that is being put
into it
and it's really it's really nice to
watch the the the end result
of course it looks like
easy yeah look it looks like you did it
in an afternoon exactly
ah while yawning
uh real real quick because i gotta go um
what's the status of you and patty doing
cleopatra is that still happening
cleopatra is definitely still happening
we have an amazing script and i cannot
wait to celebrate and bring her story to
to the big screen
i gotta go congrats on the movie like i
said it's gonna be a huge [ __ ] thank you
for your time thank you
you